Oh God how do people that do this well, do it well?
Hi, my name is Grace Helbig, if you did not know, now you know your life is different now!
u mmmmm. That's as far as I've thought out this video. Thus far. It is homecoming season, it's also
Halloween season. Some of you might not know what one of those things
Are. Homecoming is a dance that happens for high schoolers in the fall where they had to dress up in elaborate
Attire and Halloween is the same thing. So I thought it would be fun to merge the two
And I was going to recreate one of my high school homecoming looks. The first picture I have is this one.
Look at the comfort level of this stick bug. I think this is me in ninth grade.
I actually made this dress because I had a sewing machine from Joanne's Fabric, and you can see I
sort of knew how to use a sewing machine,
but I did not know how to use an iron.
The second look is my 10th grade homecoming look, which is
yowzer
I am sweating New Jersey out of every orifice in this look. I did not make this look.
It doesn't make this look any better, or worse,
but I think I was one of the only girls at homecoming that decided that I should have a two-piece
ensemble with texture.
In keeping with my former self,
I went to Joanne's Fabrics
and I bought some fabric. I decided that I wanted to recreate one, if not both, of these
iconic Grace Helbig homecoming looks, that could also be used as an iconic Halloween look. Go as a throwback Thursday.
Let's just do it. First things first, going to Joanne's Fabrics to buy fabric for this type of video was stressful.
I had to go buy this pink satin fabric, a lot of it, and pretend like I was doing something like
normal with it. It's very see-through. You can't really tell. How many fingers
am I holding up? Just one. Let's get started on this 10th grade iconic Grace Helbig homecoming look.
I'm gonna readjust you now. Whoa okay? Sure, that's good. And we're cutting it. No one looks up close.
It's like every high schooler's rule of thumb, regardless of like formal dance or whatever - don't look up close.
Okay, okay, so far we might have something.
I also bought a handheld stitching machine,
which I tested out. I made
myself a pillow on my couch yesterday, instead of doing any work that I should have. I should have shot this video yesterday,
but I didn't. I used this to make a pillow for my couch. I also have a hot glue gun. We're just recreating,
I'm not actually going to a dance in this, so it doesn't have to be functional. Neither were any of the outfits that I actually
created for myself before. I'm gonna put some Spanx on and I'm gonna get some safety pins.
What a look. Why doesn't this safety penetrate this fabric? Also, why is this safety pin so rusted? There's a lot of questions.
Oh there we go. Whoa. Whoa. Whoa. Whoa.
Beautiful princess skirt. Time for the shirt. Every South Jersey girl's dream in
2001 was to have a shirt that you could pet. Remember those shirts that were super tiny that you'd buy from Sam's Club that looked
like accordions, and then they'd become real shirts?
Yeah,
this is sort of like that, but not at all. So, it sheds so much, and wow,
also extraordinarily see- through. You can take the girl out of Jersey, you can't get the Jersey to stop trying to make the girl be a slut.
I'm kidding, I'm kidding, I'm kidding. Beautiful, wonderful humans come from New Jersey. Hmm. This is basically "Will It Kini?", but "Will It Homecoming?" Hmm. Armpit? Well, alright.
Okay, okay. Here we go. That is a long neckline.
Eat sh*t
Project Runway. Also, I would love to be a judge at one point. Wow, that looks so good.
Let's cut the back of the shirt. There's fur everywhere.
That's my impersonation of,
like, when two furries get together and consummate their relationship
I have no idea what this fabric could actually be used for, but I bought it.
I don't know why I'm doing this whole bit in the skirt. Just to prove that how functional the skirt is, guys.
Let's hot glue this shirt together. Ain't nobody got time for it. I mean, you were great in theory. Here
we go. I've had my hot glue warming up. I pre-planned. And it's off. It turned out it turned itself off.
Oh, damn it. While the hot glue is warming up, let's clean up.
Ow. Ow. Ow.
Okay, so we're gonna let our beautiful top cool down. The hot glue. Then we're gonna try it inside out
I'm gonna, meanwhile, do some quick hair and makeup kind of stuff to make it look like I'm in my 10th grade
homecoming outfit. None of this is unhealthy for my growth as an adult.
Oh, I cut it perfectly. Let's fix hair. My hair for this had all these, like, spiral little things that were hugely popular,
and I have tape-in extensions in the front of my hair now, that I can't necessarily do,
but let's see how we can make something similar happen. Yeah.
I'm sorry that your football lost, but I'm transforming myself into my 10th grade self,
so there's priorities that are happening. So the top, guys, the top part feels as much as I can
match to my hair at the time. I don't have long hair right now, but I do have this. My god.
Let's cut to the final product, please.
Wow and also wow. This has taken way longer than expected. Should this be a tag?
Should I tag people in this? I'm gonna tag a couple people to recreate one of their old cringy looks, whether it is a
formal dance or just a Halloween costume or miscellaneous
moment. I'm gonna tag Hannah,
Mamrie, Tyler, and Colleen, cause Colleen has so many photos and videos from when she was younger.
What should we call this tag? This already exists, I'm sure this already exists. I'm so old, but am I? Yeah.
Let me know what we should call this tag, and also let Hannah, Mamrie, Tyler, and Colleen know that they should participate. Make sure you subscribe
to my Youtube channel if you haven't already, because I make awe-inspiring content. Click that bell notification
so you get notified when I make videos, because so many of you don't get notified, and this is content
you don't want to miss. Other than that, I don't know. This has been a lot.